we have to be in the Forefront of the
research Innovation and production from
the cutting-edge technology in the cheap
production
it is about millions and millions of
small pieces transistors which are the
basics of electronics what they are
using for
in our day-to-day life almost everything
you cannot actually find one small
object you are using in your daily life
without achievement smartphones from
appliances cars
because the increase of demand back 10 5
15 years ago how many chips in the
normal car in my bearish car one five
ten now an electric car 3000 chips
[Music]
our consumption of chips it's important
in the European Union we are not able to
produce chips native enclosed to the to
what is our needs and that's why
we have this new strategy to bring
foreign investors to invest to invest in
European union and to be able to
increase the chief's production
if the Chiefs are produced in Europe
then you can be sure that whatever will
happen in this world you'll be able to
have your day-to-day life as usual
because otherwise we'll be exposed to
all International crises so let's learn
after the war in Ukraine is that we have
to be sure that we have a certain level
of the critical
needs
ensure of of the EU production it'll
have to shorten the world the production
chains
we have a clear framework of what you
will find if you want to invest in the
chips in the European Union if you
qualify for a stated you'll get it
you'll get it fast it will get it where
you need it that's why we are happy to
have this uh the chips act in place as
soon as possible to be able to provide
the necessary support for the investors
and to show them investing in Europe
it is a friendly environment and we are
very much welcome to do that foreign